[Música]
todos los días nos levantamos y hacemos
uso de recursos y productos que nos da
la naturaleza nos levantamos y nos
tomamos un baño se han preguntado alguna
vez de dónde viene esa agua de qué río
de qué de manantial el desayuno que
tomamos la manzana la papaya de dónde
vienen tienen idea
no sabemos y más aún qué pasa con los
desechos cuando vamos al baño hacemos
pipí le jalan aún se va todo eso todos
esos desperdicios se van a un río o
pasan por una planta de tratamiento han
pesado qué pasa con toda la caca que
producimos los humanos dónde está la
vemos el más qué pasa con toda la caca
que producen los animales las vacas los
borregos los burros los perros dónde
está
[Música]
en méxico solamente hay 32 millones de
vacas 32 millones de cabezas de ganado
cada vaca en promedio hace nueve
toneladas de caca al año lo equivalente
a 10 millones de containers si lo
pusiéramos todo junto en forma lineal le
daría 5 vueltas a la tierra imagínense
toda esa caca sin embargo no la vemos de
repente vamos un poco porque no la vemos
resulta que hay unos escarabajos que se
encargan de retirar todos esos
excrementos de la superficie de la
tierra
los escarabajos macho hacen una bolita
de estiércol
y las hembras deciden con quién
aparearse dependiendo quién hizo la
bolita más elegante más bonita más
redondita y entonces deciden a ese macho
si me gusta se aparean ruedan juntos la
bolita y la hembra pone los huevos
dentro de esa bolita de caca pero la
bolita de caca no se queda sobre la
superficie sino que la entierran
entonces además de estar quitándonos
toda la caca que está sobre el suelo
están fertilizando
entonces imagínense ese papel
fundamental que están realizando los
escarabajos por nosotros que ni siquiera
habíamos pensado
no lo habían pensado ustedes yo no me me
gustan los insectos entonces por eso
investiga un poco pero resulta que los
insectos
también están en peligro
seguramente han escuchado que las
ballenas están en peligro que los tigres
de bengala están en peligro
pero han pensado que los insectos
también están disminuyendo lo que
pensamos al ver a un insecto es ese
me va a picar ese es
ponzoñoso ese es sucio y entonces
hay que matarlos
entonces muchos insectos se están
extinguiendo en alemania recientemente
hicieron un estudio en donde evaluaron
cuántos insectos había en áreas
naturales protegidas y han venido
haciendo este estudio desde hace 30 años
entonces tienen datos muy buenos para
comparar cuáles son las tendencias y el
resultado es terrible resulta que hoy en
día hay 70 por ciento menos insectos de
lo que había hace 30 años 70% ya nos
echamos a todos esos insectos y como
puede ser que se están extinguiendo pues
principalmente porque las áreas
prístinas que teníamos los bosques las
selvas los pastizales pues hoy en día
están convertidos a campos agrícolas
campos ganaderos o en ciudades
pues no solamente les quitamos el
hábitat sino que además
utilizamos muchos agroquímicos
insecticidas que fueron diseñados para
matar a las plagas pero que además están
matando a otros insectos muchos que
tienen
cuestiones benéficas para los humanos y
otros que no sabemos que hacen por
nosotros entonces la forma en que
tenemos de aprovechar el medio ambiente
hace que lo estemos matando
seguramente han escuchado en las
noticias recientemente sobre el problema
con las abejas
y las abejas las abejas mieleras que son
fundamentales para la polinización de
muchos cultivos hoy en día están
colapsando y como nos dimos cuenta que
estaban colapsando no es porque
estuviéramos muy preocupados por las
abejas sino que los cultivos empezaron a
no tener frutos en algunos lugares en
particular el cultivo de almendras en
california tuvo unas pérdidas
importantísimas y cuando vieron qué es
lo que está pasando pues resulta que las
colmenas de las abejas que polinizan
estos lugares tenían muy poquitas abejas
o estaban colapsando al estudiar un poco
más porque estaban colapsando se dieron
cuenta que tenían muchas enfermedades y
que los insecticidas que estaban
diseñados para matar a las plagas si
bien no matan a las abejas hacen que
éstas se desorienten entonces no pueden
regresar a sus colmenas y eso hace que
las colmenas desaparezcan
qué triste no que estemos haciendo este
impacto sobre las abejas es tan
importante el servicio que nos brindan
que se ha calculado que si se
extinguieran todos los polinizadores del
en particular de los cultivos de los
humanos el servicio anual sería de dos
mil millones de dólares imagínense todo
ese servicio que nadie paga
eso lo hacen las abejas por nosotros si
tuviéramos que hacerlo de manera manual
y llevar polen de una flor a otra para
que se produzca una almendra eso es lo
que nos costaría
si no fuera por los polinizadores
nuestra dieta sería terrible piensen
ustedes nada más todas las frutas y
verduras que son polinizadas por
insectos el jitomate la manzana la pera
la papaya
la piña el chile la calabaza el frijol
si no fuera por estos insectos
polinizadores solamente comeríamos
pastos y vacas
nuestra dieta sería muy triste entonces
este servicio que nos están brindando
los polinizadores pues hay que
reconocerlo hay que hacerlo visible y es
importante decir que no son solamente
las abejas famosas que hoy están en las
noticias porque esta es una especie hay
miles de especies de abejas que también
están haciendo los servicios no solo
para las plantas cultivadas sino las
para las plantas que están en los
ecosistemas
que se están disminuyendo
[Música]
entonces tenemos que cambiar la forma en
que nos relacionamos con el ambiente
dejando de producir tantos químicos
tóxicos y pensando más en cómo podemos
utilizar la misma biodiversidad para
producir y utilizar a las especies
nativas como utilizamos a las especies
de abejas nativas pues dejando los
bosques donde viven esos bosques si
queremos politizar el aguacate en lugar
de tumbar los bosques podemos dejar
manchones de bosque para que de ahí
salgan las abejas que vayan a polinizar
entonces la próxima vez que vean un
insecto que les cruza por enfrente en
lugar de matarlo porque no piensan que
podrá ser estar haciendo este insecto
por nosotros que todavía no hemos
descubierto
bueno
los invito a que pensemos en todo esto
que están haciendo por nosotros
[Aplausos]
[Música]